weg ist der donald trump nach florida
die welt atmet durch
doch zum happy end ist es noch ein
weiter weg ungewiss ob es jemals
erreicht wird mit den neuen mann im
weißen haus und irgendwann vielleicht
mit einer frau der amtswechsel schafft
beiden den neustart jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde heute an diesem januartag
will meine ganze seele amerika zusammen
bringen unser volk vereinen unsere
nationen vereinen ich rufe jeden
amerikaner auf mir dabei zu folgen so
josef robiné beiden junior der 46
präsident der usa heute auf den stufen
des kapitols nach seiner vereidigung und
damit herzlich willkommen liebe
zuschauer bei uns im studio für meine
gäste zu sechs im studio soraya so hat
die nelson ist us amerikanische
journalistin hier in berlin in berlin
ist auch tätig christoph von marschall
diplomatischer korrespondent der
chefredaktion des tagesspiegel
zugeschaltet aus boston ist uns katrin
klüber genauer gesagt aus einem vorort
von boston namens cambridge statt ist
sitzt die berühmte harvard university
und sie sind an der harvard kennedy
school tätig und leitete dort ein
forschungsprojekt für transatlantische
beziehungen und aus washington
zugeschaltet ist uns meinte machata
sie sind nordamerika korrespondent der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung von
elson war das heute ein historischer tag
ja ein sehr historischer tag und auch
ein tag der erleichterung glaube ich für
die mehrheit von amerikaner es war also
ich glaube mehrere haben geweint also
die tränen fließen weil das war wirklich
vier jahre von viel stress hier gemerkt
viele amerikaner sind sie aus boston
zugeschaltet klassische ostküste joe
biden land was wird denn jetzt aus dem
fly over country also den mittleren
westen wo man immer nur drüber fliegt
und wo die anhänger von donald trump
wohnen ja wenn man herrn beiden waren
glauben schenken soll dann geht jetzt
erstmal die phase des großen zuhörens
los und die phase der resultate für
diese menschen
denn wenn der nun geschiedene präsident
damit schon bei seiner anrede von dem
beginnen amerikanischen gemetzel
berichtet hatte seine arme
antrittsrede dann war das doch ein ganz
anderes signal jetzt soll es kühn jetzt
soll es optimistisch weiter gehen und
vor allen dingen hat er sich dazu
verschworen jetzt gerade auch für die
mitte des landes resultate zu
präsentieren und zwar schnell
das warten hat viel angekündigt
freispruch hat es ja gerade gesagt was
davon wird ihm denn schnell gelingen und
wo wird es probleme möglicherweise sogar
blockaden geben um das umzusetzen was er
sich jetzt vorgenommen hat also er hat
ja schon gesagt dass er angesichts der
lage zwei schwerpunkte hat das eine ist
natürlich die bekämpfung der pandemie
und damit zusammenhängen dass zweite die
wiederbelebung der wirtschaft
ich glaube auf diesen beiden baustellen
gibt es auch am ehesten hoffnung dass
man das schnell im einsamen mit
bekannten hinbekommt durchregieren wird
es nicht geben obwohl er jetzt in beiden
kongresskammern eine mehrheit hat
es gibt einen konservativen flügel
innerhalb der demokratischen partei der
verhindern wird dass die linken
präsenten haus sitzen sozusagen
irgendwann durchsetzen was also
institutionelle reformen denke ich damit
er nicht sehr weit kommen was die reform
des verfassungsgerichtes rekord
anbelangt was die aufnahme weiterer
bundesstaaten also washington dc als
eigentlich unbeschadet klammer auf mit
zwei senatoren puerto rico als eigener
staat mit zwei senatoren das wird es
nicht geben
von marschall in angesicht der
himmelblauen air force one waren die
letzten worte von donald trump heute
morgen kurz vor dem abflug nach florida
auf dem flugfeld andrews air force base
wir werden wiederkommen in welcher form
auch immer war das als drogen gemeint na
ja die hoffnung für seine anhänger auf
aufrecht dass er eben doch noch
politische macht hat oder wieder haben
wird
versuchte auch immer wieder zu flott mit
dieser idee könnte nochmal antreten ich
halte das für sehr unrealistisch
für bolt am platz jetzt ungemütlich denn
er hat die immunität des amtes nicht
mehr und er hat auch keine selbst
begnadigung ausgesprochen darüber
spekuliert zwar seitdem auch gar nichts
geholfen denn erstens ist dieser schritt
umstritten
zweitens schützen begnadigung nur vor
vergehen gegen bundesrecht aber die
wirklich gefährlichen ermittlungen die
schon seit jahren laufen und im moment
nur unterbrochen waren die sind hier auf
einzelstaaten ebene in new york wird
ermittelt gegen steuerhinterziehung den
versicherungsbetrug wegen
bilanzfälschung in washington dort
ermittelt wegen selbst begünstigung und
verstoß gegen wahlkampf gesetze es gibt
frauen die ihn wegen sexueller
belästigung oder gar vergewaltigung vor
gericht bringen wollen
also ich glaube dort schon für die
nächsten wochen und monate damit zu tun
haben sich ein gutes anwaltsteam
zusammenzustellen
und es geht nicht nur um strafrechtliche
dinge sondern auch seinen ganzer nimbus
als geschäftsmann dass er darunter
leiden wer will noch mit ihm geschäfte
machen
jemand der als schlächter präsident in
die geschichte eingeht womöglich mit
gerichtsverfahren und gefängnis rechnen
muss und donald trump geschäftsprinzip
war er verkauft seinen namen er hat ja
nicht reale unternehmen nimmt
lizenzgebühren für die nutzung seines
namens ein
also ich glaube für den standort ist ja
ungemütlich und das bedeutet dass die
chancen für ein politisches comeback
doch eher gering sind ich will jetzt
nicht sagen überhaupt nicht vorhanden
kann viel passieren amerika nächsten
vier jahren aber im moment als heutiger
sicht ist erstmal die macht wenn man
sich die biografien von donald trump und
joe biden an sie dann können die
unterschiedlicher nicht sein will dass
jetzt die man von donald trump weg und
schauen auf den neuen präsidenten
der ist im jahre 1973 als senator zum
ersten mal vereidigt wird am krankenbett
seiner beiden söhne die bei einem nur
einen einen schweren autounfall nur
knapp überlebt haben bei dem seine frau
und seine tochter ums leben kamen einer
der beiden söhne die das schwer verletzt
worden ist später an einem tumor
verstorben wenn eine solche
schicksalsschläge nicht verbittern
sondern seinen charakter stärken ist das
sozusagen
die beste voraussetzungen für dieses amt
ja also ich gerade jetzt wo unser land
so leidet und wurde also die leute so
gestaltet sind dass so ein mensch der so
viel mitgemacht hat vielleicht doch am
besten also man sieht ihm an als ein
statesman lehmann auf englisch sagt also
der ist ein älterer mann der auch sehr
gut sprechen kann ich meine wenigstens
kann also einer setzte von anfang bis
zum entsprechen und ich meine mit trump
war das ja immer schwierig und er redet
immer über wir also was wir machen und
44 amerika und ich bin für euch da und
das ist eine ganz andere art als was wir
jetzt gesehen haben die letzten vier
jahre woher kommt alles also alles von
seiner sicht aus und alles für sich und
nicht für die amerikaner getan hat und
gerade jetzt wo wir diese
herausforderung mit die pandemie haben
also da ist glaube ich dass das sein
also was ja herr beiden schon in sein
leben mitgemacht hat das helfen wir
klüger eschborn joe biden ist ja der
prototyp des washingtoner establishment
seit sind das jetzt 47 jahre wenn ich
das richtig 48 jahre ist er da im
geschäft politisch erst im senat an war
er vizepräsident jetzt ist er präsident
geworden kann es sein dass trotzdem die
leute die eigentlich dieses engagement
ablehnen
diese lebens- und leidensweg von joe
biden würdigen und ihnen in ihm doch ein
großes vorbild sehen auch wenn sie jetzt
keine anhänger der demokraten sind also
ich glaube schon die biografie also die
den leidensweg des joe biden
das ist einer der ihn unglaublich auch
empathisch und sympathisch macht er hat
auch in seiner langen und an der zeit
nie die bodenhaftung verloren fuhr immer
mit dem antrag abends nach hause das
hehre ziel war mit seinen söhnen abend
zu essen er war lange allein erziehender
vater
das sind so erfahrungen die ihnen auch
mit vielen amerikanern verbinden und es
ist ein mann der für integrität steht
anders als der nun aus dem amt
geschiedene präsident rampf der
natürlich auch seine familie so ins
spiel gebracht hat dass es rot ismus war
herr von marschall hat schon
besprochen was da nicht nur ihm sondern
eben auch seiner familie noch drohen
kann
das ist ein einen donut ein joe biden
ist ein ganz anderer mensch und er hat
heute ein offenes angebot gemacht in
seiner rede zu den amerikanern gesagt
geben sie mir als person eine chance er
spricht in einer einfachen sprache er
spricht quasi als mensch als amerikaner
zu den amerikanern in einem ganz
einfachen klaren drucklos das ist auch
ein mann der sich öfter mal eine träne
verdrückt der bei seinem abschied von
delaware gestern sagte denn er wird auf
meinem grabstein geschrieben sein als
würde zwischen del und washington eine
lange durststrecke liegen dabei ist das
mal anderthalb stunden fahrt also das
ist ein mann der sehr boden verhaftet
ist der sich als kind von schwer
arbeiten amerikanern versteht werk an
empathie und für sich begeistern und der
kann auch einen großen teil der mieter
glaube ich wieder hinter das hat habe
man sich diese rede ansieht dann sind da
begriffe gefallen ich würde noch mal
einige versöhnung also im übertragenen
sinn gemeint sind patriotismus darüber
hat er viel gesprochen
auf der anderen seite aber wirklich
gesagt hat von chaos geredet von
spaltung sogar von bürgerkrieg mit all
diesen begriffen hat er die den heutigen
zustand der usa gemeint das ist eine
ziemlich nüchterne und schonungslose
bestandsaufnahme seines eigenen landes
und klingt zunächst mal nach ganz schön
vielen moll tönen
ja hallo angesichts der ereignisse von
vor zwei wochen am selben ort im kapitol
waren die worte gleichwohl angemessen
ich habe die herausforderung vor der
beiden jetzt steht es dass er ein spagat
leisten muss herstellern meist muss und
zwar einerseits die hand ausstrecken die
amerikanische politik entgiften auf die
republikaner zugehen auf die moderaten
republikaner die kompromissbereit sind
andererseits und es gewinnt heute wird
er vieles von dem was in den vergangenen
vier jahren verziert zu korrigieren r
setzt sich heute abend hier hin im
weißen haus und wird zu 10x sektor ist
und dass
zeichnen mit denen er viele dinge die
tram eingeführt hat wieder abschafft
also eintritt denn im pariser pinakothek
ist gerade in der meldung bekommen dass
er das so zu sagen so eben gemacht hat
das hat er ja auch angekündigt den
pariser abkommen wieder beizutreten
genau dann die der travel wenn also das
reise vor ein reiseverbot für
mehrheitlich muslimische staaten wird
auch gut aufgehoben
mit der einschränkung dass man natürlich
die reisebeschränkungen die wegen der
wegen der pandemie beschrieben weiter
achtet das ist also zunächst als mal
symbolischer natur was da gemacht wird
die politik der kinder trennung die ist
zu beginn von fans angst hat die immer
latent immer noch dazu führt dass viele
familien getrennt sind
diddy soll korrigiert werden und man
wird ja jetzt viel energie reinstecken
diese familien wieder zusammenführen zu
können
als er wird das hat ja nur symbolik dass
das alles heute unterzeichnet wird und
im hardcore lager der trappisten wird
das natürlich nicht als versöhnliches
signal wahrgenommen und das ist meine
ich mit spagat hat er ist auch die
moderaten kräfte zugegangen und ich
schlimm von der jetzt in zürich wird
sogar so weit gehen
man hat heute einigen amerikanern auf
dem kapitolshügel angesehen dass die
tief durchgeatmet haben und eigentlich
froh sind dass job weg ist aber es gibt
eben auch die anderen und was christoph
von marschall gesagt hat das ist richtig
ich glaube auch dass trump feststellen
wird dass von florida aus sich in
washington nicht regieren er hat
allerdings noch destruktive macht er
kann schon bei den midterm elections
sind zwei jahren dafür sorgen dass in
den vorwahlen der republikaner
trappisten gegen moderate republikaner
antreten
er kandidiere die detaillisten die
bereits in washington mandatsträger sind
einsetzen um den anderen republikaner
das leben schwer zu machen also
destruktiv gemacht hat er noch und so
wie er ist wird er die auch einsetzen
wenn er wenn man sich die rede ansieht
wir vielleicht noch auf ein zitat sehen
ganz am anfang der rede sagte er dies
ist der tag der demokratie also heute
wir haben erneut gelernt dass demokratie
kostbar ist fragil in dieser stunde
meine freunde hat sich die demokratie
durchgesetzt also auch da ja dieser
molto dass die usa ja möglicherweise
doch an einer ziemlichen politischen
katastrophe an dem desaster am sechsten
januar vorbei geschlittert sind steckt
das den amerikanern noch in den knochen
wer jetzt gefährlich nein zu sagen weil
natürlich ist noch in den knochen steckt
und dennoch glaube ich dass da auch noch
ein anderer aspekt zu beobachten ist was
beiden heute gemacht hat
die rede war hat sich im wesentlichen an
die emotionen ans herz gewandt er hat
versucht das ideale amerika wie es sein
sollte was die amerikaner verbinde zu
beschreiben und auf der anderen seite
als ging und so gefährlich ist wenn wir
nicht diesen weg gehe nicht was nicht
überrascht hat ist wie unkonkret er war
er hat ja im prinzip nur lauter
abstrakte ziele beschrieben er ist für
mehr gesundheit erstmal für bildung
erstmal für gerechtigkeit aber das wie
das wievielte inaugurationsrede ist doch
eigentlich die regierungserklärung
und natürlich ist es mehr ein
rhetorisches werk als jetzt sozusagen
erstens zweitens drittens wirkens aber
bei obama bei trump hat bei allem großen
bogen doch immer durch geschieden und
das möchte ich in den ersten monaten tun
das ist dafür bin ich angetreten
das fehlte alles beiden und da muss man
sich doch fragen warum fehlt das weil
beiden weiß wie fragil seine
möglichkeiten sind er hat nur eine sehr
knappe mehrheit ich wollte euch jetzt
mal sehr zugespitzt sagen der muss diese
dekrete auch unterschreiben als
trostpflaster weil die gesetzgebung die
den für den kurz die nie kommen wird es
wird kein neues integrationsgesetz gehen
es wird in den nächsten zwei jahren kein
gesetz über steuererhöhungen geben all
das was die partei im wahlkampf
versprochen hat und wo die linke
parteibasis doch jetzt will das dass
geliefert wird und wo auch die großteil
der 81 millionen wähler möchte dass das
jetzt habt ihr doch gesagt das müssen
wir jetzt kommen wir haben einen
präsidenten wir haben's abgeordnetenhaus
wir haben den senat ja auf dem papier
aber die ganzen konservativen
demokratischen senatoren die werden sich
sehr genau überlegen bei welchen
gesetzes projekten die einen kurswechsel
bedeuten würden sie mitmachen oder er
nicht mitmachen weil das ihre wiederwahl
gefährdet
also was beiden heute gemacht hat das
eigentlich
er hat anerkannt dass es erwartungen
gibt aber er hat nicht gesagt dass er
sie erfüllen wird und das ist letzten
endes aus meiner sicht expectation
management er hat die erwartungen
gedämpft er versucht die erwartungen die
im wahlkampf geweckt worden sind jetzt
langsam abzugleichen mit dem was er
persönlich will er ist ein moderater
demokratie ist kein linker demokrat und
was wir überhaupt machen kann mit den
machtverhältnissen die er hat also wir
müssen da ein bisschen erwartungen
reduzieren und das ist in der rede eben
auch angriff also wenn man erst
erwartungen erweckt bei allem
wahlkampfgetöse das gibt es ja auch bei
uns und dann erwartungen dämpft dann
müssen sich doch die ein oder anderen
wähler die joe biden geklaut haben die
ihn auch deswegen gewählt haben ja
eigentlich auch so ein bisschen den
tisch gezogen fühlen wenn er jetzt da
nicht liefern kann vorherigen den ersten
beiden jahren wo im kongress jahr beide
häuser auf seiner seite stimmt ja also
es wird enttäuschung geben viele
demokraten die grade die progressive die
linke seite von der partei aber man muss
auch denken was konnten zwei jahren oder
was kommt in vier jahren an bin
man hat angst dass der traum zurückkommt
oder so einer wieder traum zu sagen dass
74 millionen leute sind die vier traum
gewählt haben und dass die wie gesagt
die südrampe kandidaten dann nachher
einsetzen ich glaube das wird den beiden
ein bisschen schützen und das wird auch
also die angst wird vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr sein als die enttäuschung
und da aber wie die haben wir schon
gesagt hat also er konnte heute wirklich
nicht sehr viel versprechen weil er kann
nicht sehr viel tun also mit 50 50 und
dann kam kamalla herres ist dann die die
wahl die da die demokraten bisschen über
über die mehrheit gibt es ist nicht
genug um überhaupt etwas durchzusetzen
frau köhler schlug fehl da
möglicherweise auch ein positives
narrativ im radio so schön sagt für das
regierungsprogramm der muss ja zunächst
mal bekämpfen
er muss die pandemie bekämpfen er muss
die mögliche rezession bekämpfen er muss
den rassismus bekämpfen und so ewig lang
funktioniert das ja nicht mit der
ausrede das haben wir alle starts ab zu
verdanken sondern er muss dann auch
eigene akzente setzte und er ist auch
für die politischen entscheidungen für
das was jetzt in washington oder
überhaupt in den usa passiert
verantwortlich ist dass möglicherweise
auch eine hypothek dass dieses diese
positive botschaft im moment nicht so
richtig bei den wirklich wichtigen jetzt
als erstes zu erledigenden sachen
möglich ist naja so er hat ist heute
schon so in die sprache der chancen
verpackt das würde sonst auch nicht in
amerikanische b
also hat schon immer hier mit einer sehr
optimistischen sprache gearbeitet aber
sie haben recht die herausforderungen
sind groß denn wir müssen vielleicht
auch mal dazu sagen dass diese mehrheit
im senat wirklich eigentlich nur in
großen budget und finanzfragen hilfe
alles andere braucht man im senat
größere mehrheiten das heißt es muss
schwer verhandelt werden also zb jetzt
bei fragen der klima und energiepolitik
die uns europäer natürlich besonders
angehen und wohl gerade mit dem mit der
ernennung eines john kerry nach außen
und anderen china mit kaffee aus einer
gestandenen klima politikerin nach innen
quasi schon gleich feiler gesetzt hat
aber wo dann die frage ist wie überzeugt
er dann den senator von die senatoren
aus west virginia davon zum beispiel von
der ölindustrie schnelle abzutreten ja
das sind ganz andere wirkliche
praktische fragen also das hat ja von
marschall glaube ich ganz schön erklärt
also er muss jetzt schauen wie er
schnell ps auf die straße bringen kann
wie er seine partei zusammenhält und und
das ist wirklich der ganz grosse
unsicherheitsfaktor was machen die
republikaner entdecken sie jetzt doch
noch ihr rückgrat für die demokratie
denken sie dass die koalition nach innen
also dass das gefüge der
republikanischen partei geben kempis
muss nach außen einhalt gebieten kann
dass sie sich eine mehrheit vielleicht
2020 sein sohn noch sichern kann
oder gewinnt die fraktion und hält kurs
und roche holly weil es da eben um ganz
ganz enge wahlbezirke geht und das ist
dass das ja ganz große unsicherheit
moment für jobs daher kann ich das gut
verstehen dass er eigentlich in dieser
rede war - und es passt natürlich auch
zum einfachen sprachduktus christo
beiden und so seinen eigenen
persönlichen stil
er muss ja das land einerseits einen
anders jetzt haben wir das ja schon
mehrfach gehört das ist gar nicht mal so
einfach also eine mehrheit im senat ist
was anderes
das hätte man oder im repräsentantenhaus
als hätte man ihm mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag wo die fraktionsführung
eigentlich alles bestimmt das heißt also
es klingt ja jetzt so dass joe biden
quasi ein jongleur sein muss der mit
einer ganzen menge bälle gleichzeitig in
der luft schockieren muss um überhaupt
einen einen roten faden für seine
politik zu finden und wenigsten die
wichtigsten sachen in seiner ganzen
politischen agenda zumindest in den
nächsten zwei jahren durchzusetzen
ja oder eben wirklich die erwartungen
reduzieren ich entwerfe mal gerade wie
könnt ihr das denn aussehen wenn die
amerikaner und auch der rest der welt
das gefühl hätte der mann hat eigentlich
schon seine schuldigkeit getan und seine
verantwortung erfüllt wenn es ihm
gelingt mal ruhe in den laden zu bringen
dass wir nicht jeden morgen wieder
aufwachen was kommen heute wieder für
aufregende tweets wer wird heute wieder
polarisiert provoziert sonst was wenn er
fortschritte macht bei der bekämpfung
der korona pandemie das wäre ja schon
mal wahnsinnig wichtig sowohl
gesundheitspolitisch als natürlich auch
wirtschaftspolitisch also wenn er das
schafft ruhe in den laden bringen dass
die aggressivität nicht mehr zunimmt
sondern vielleicht langfristig ein
bisschen reduziert war dass man wieder
ein bisschen mehr respekt vor anderen
meinungen hat dann musste er gar nicht
viel mehr machen ich also ich persönlich
werde beiden verzeihung nicht daran
messen wie viele grundlegende reformen
in den nächsten zwei bis vier jahren
durch bringt sondern wenn amerika wieder
ein verlässliches landwirt für seine
bürger aber auch für die partner in der
welt dann wäre ich eigentlich schon ganz
zufrieden und wurde ihm geradezu
verzeihen
das von vielen wahlkampfversprechen und
das meiste nicht erfüllt worden
das erwarten wir auch viele kommen
vergleich noch mal drauf zurück katar
was katrin krüger sporadisch schon
gesagt hat in bezug auf die republikaner
und deren zukunft haben sie da eine idee
was besser gesagt welche richtung sich
da durchsetzen könnte also die moderate
letztendlich auch an politischer arbeit
interessierte konstruktive richtung oder
die trump ist ische die eigentlich davon
lebt dass das chaos weiter geht und dass
das politische system der usa irgendwie
destabilisiert wird also manchmal konnte
der bisherige märz
und jetzt künftige minderheitsführer der
republikaner im senat gestern im
plenarsaal ja sozusagen beiden das
angebot erwiderten hat gesagt also wenn
ihr mir nicht mit einer linken agenda
kommt ihr die beiden administrationen
dann lasse ich mit mir reden dann lassen
wir mit uns reden und ich glaube das
betrifft die großen themen die wir schon
andere vornamen pandemie
wirtschaftskrise infrastrukturprojekte
investitionsprogramm
da ist sicherlich spielraum man wird
sehen können in welche richtung das bei
den republikanern geht wenn man sich
anschaut wie das jetzt mit dem
management prozesse nach läuft der von
dem wir noch nicht genau wissen wann der
beginnt aber manchmal konnte hat gestern
der formulierung gewählt die vielfach so
interpretiert wird als könnte eher dazu
neigen für eine verurteilung führten zu
schwimmen mit dem ziel zu verhindern
dass er 24 zurückkommt ich würde ehrlich
gesagt so weit nicht gehen er sprach
davon dass trump diesen sturm auf das
kapital profitiert hat bewusst glaube
ich produziert gesagt und nicht
angestiftet und nicht den rechts
terminus zu wählen
und ich glaube das hauptziel eines
matchballs ist momentan eine spaltung
der republikanischen partei zu
verhindern
insofern bin ich eher skeptisch dass es
zu einer verurteilung kommt das würde
natürlich dazu führen dass das lager der
trappisten in der anhängerschaft sich
gegen das establishment der partei in
washington wenden würde und dass das ist
das womit ich rechne dass es dass er am
ende da nicht mitmacht und das dann am
ende auch sozusagen die
zweidrittelmehrheit im senat fehlt und
tram tatsächlich zu verurteilen dann
wird diese frage aber auch offen bleiben
so sagen die republikaner müssen etwas
liefern
die können einfach nicht nein sagen und
die gegner partei sagen und immer
opposition partei die immer nein sagt
die müssen diesmal etwas liefern gerade
dieser moderaten die im senat sitzen
also die können weil die wirtschaft ist
kaputt nicht nur für leute die
demokratisch geführt haben aber auch für
die die verträumt gewählt haben und wenn
die etwas zeigen können
dann hilft das glaube ich dass die
partei vielleicht sich zusammenhält und
nicht nur immer in diese richtung diese
richtung weitergeht weil das ist eine
richtige gefahr dass diese kandidaten
und und auch im haus der repräsentanten
da sind ja viele von diese pisten die da
sind als das team das die weiter die
macht erhalten werden und dagegen muss
mich da müssen andere ankomme und
deswegen glaube ich dass die nicht
einfach gegen die demokraten stehen
werden dass die vielleicht doch
wirtschaftlich wenigstens was schaffen
werden und gegen die pandemie frau weiß
schon welche rolle spielen denn in dem
zusammenhang die richter in den usa also
das supreme court vor allen dingen ja
auch in vielen umstrittenen politisch
umstrittenen fragen dann entscheidet der
eine enorme macht ist ja mehrheitlich
konservativ besetzt
übertreibt man da den oder über so hat
man den einfluss oder sieht man denn als
zu groß an oder wird diese supreme court
oder andere gerichte die ja auch eine
wichtige rolle jetzt zum beispiel
gespielt haben auch bei der frage ob das
wahlergebnis korrekt zustande gekommen
ist welche rolle spielt die justiz in
die politische justiz in den usa in den
nächsten vier jahren
ich sage mal ein halbsatz zu frau hat
ihn ernst ich sehe das leider trotz
meiner eines amerikanischen passes
weniger optimistisch die republikaner
könnten es sich auch leisten ist erst
mal zwei jahre auszusetzen besonders die
senats repräsentanten um dann natürlich
zu sagen da ist es jetzt alles schief
gelaufen jetzt ist zeit 2022 wohl 34
senatssitze neu besetzt werden müssen
bzw abgestimmt werden muss denn da das
blatt zu drehen also ich glaube schon
dass mitch mcconnell
da die füße schleifen lassen ich bin da
weniger optimistisch um auch die justiz
zurück zu kommen das wird interessant
denn da wird wirklich der kultur kampf
um amerikas grundwerte weitergehen denn
eigentlich hat ja die amerikanische
demokratie enorm viel geleistet in den
letzten 15 jahren gerade die erweiterung
der minderheitsrechte und das steht
jetzt alles wieder quasi auf dem justiz
ihren zettel als annie corley war als
die zuletzt eingesetzten bundesrichterin
dazu kam
haben gleich wieder zwei konservative
bundesrichter zb gesagt ach jetzt wäre
doch die zeit sich vielleicht die
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe nochmal
vorzunehmen und bestimmte privé es die
jetzt eigentlich schon für abgeschlossen
gelten wieder aufzumachen da würde
natürlich ansturm durchs land gehen
gerade jetzt wo sich die demokraten so
er richtig aber es ist jetzt eben die
frage kommt jetzt mit dieser besetzung
und einer volleren besetzung der
konservative richter sagt man aber
eigentlich sind es eben traditionalisten
also die die auslage der verfassung
traditionell sehen als wäre es ein
dokument was sie in der zeit eingefroren
ist also nicht mit der zeit geht wie sie
ist setzt sich jetzt auf den
arbeitstitel packung schachten der
progressiven amerikanischen demokratie
wieder auseinander zu nehmen da stehen
wirklich auch sachen schon auf dem
zettel
da geht es natürlich auch um die
krankenkasse und die ganzen
gesundheitsreformen die präsident obama
damals einzig großes glanzstück in
seiner ersten amtszeit durchgebracht hat
all diese dinge stehen schon auf dem
zettel und wie diese fälle ausgehen
das wird doch entscheiden wie zum
beispiel wie schwerwiegend oder wie
wirklich institutionell der kultur kampf
in den usa weiter geführt wird
die vize präsidenten der usa führen
eigentlich immer ein schattendasein man
sagt zwar sie sind ein herzschlag weg
vom präsidentenamt und es gab auch schon
vize präsidenten die dann in ihr während
ihrer vize präsidentschaft präsident
wurden aber ansonsten fühlen sich eher
ein schatten dasein das wird aber der
neuen vize präsidentin nicht passieren
nein die hat ja einen doppeljob eben
wegen dieser knappen lage im senat sie
ist nicht nur die vize-präsidentin
sondern sie ist immer dann wenn
stimmengleichheit im senates und so ist
ja die ausgangslage fifty fifty wird sie
gebraucht als tie-break im boot als
diejenige die entscheidet und deswegen
wird kann man daher ist sehr viel zeit
im senat verbringen müssen oder sich
bereithalten müssen
das wird dann auch im wahlkampf in zwei
jahren und eben vier jahren eine rolle
spielen das wird interessant denn sie
will dir selber präsidentin werden wir
gehen ja doch eigentlich alle davon aus
dass die beiden nicht für zwei
amtszeiten sondern nur für eine amtszeit
antritt und
kamal harris ist dann in der position
dass sie die natürliche favoritin ist
für die demokratische kandidatur
und das ist auch so dieses zusatz
argument warum ich so sicher bin dass
ganz egal was joe biden will der auch
ein zentrist ist kann man daher als wird
wegen ihrer eigenen wahlchancen darauf
achten dass diese demokratische partei
nicht auf links ideologische ideen kommt
ihre aus ihrer kalkulation hängen ihre
wahlchancen 20 24 davon ab dass die
demokraten nicht in das licht eines
ideologisch linken lagers gesteckt
werden können und das wird sie glaube
ich so wird sie glaube ich auch ihre
vize präsidentschaft verstehen dass das
darauf ausgerichtet ist kontinuität
nicht nur für vier sondern für mehr
jahre zu haben und das bedeutet der
linke parteiflügel hat tendenziell
verloren
die haben noch keine alternative was
soll ich denn machen und man wird sich
gegen richtung mitte orientieren
jetzt redet ja oft von der spaltung oder
der möglichen spaltung der
republikanischen partei in diese beiden
unterschiedlichen flügel die wir gerade
schon angesprochen haben besteht eine
gefahr einer innerparteilichen
auseinandersetzung auch mit
spaltungstendenzen bei der
demokratischen partei zwischen dem
linken flügel und den moderaten flügel
auf lange sicht gesehen ja lange sicht
ja also erst ist diese honeymoon also
diese phase am anfang wo die alle
zusammen halten werden aber das dauert
nicht lange weil die also die ioc und
die andere die in die linke also der
linke teil von die demokratische partei
sitzt sind die haben jetzt die verlangen
dass hier auch etwas gemacht wird dass
die wollen und gerade mit also die
immigration und alles so was dass das
muss die wollen die die warten nicht
vier jahre bis das angesprochen wird
aber das problem ist dass joe biden also
der muss jetzt versuchen das land
zusammenzubringen und er kann einfach
nicht diese also die linke seite von die
demokratische partei zu sprechen also ja
das muss irgendwie zentral gehalten
werden wie gesagt kamera wird das auch
also versuchen aber ja es wird krach
geben ich nehme an also nicht vielleicht
ein jahr gleich sechs monate lässt dann
fängt es an mazda aus ihrer erfahrung
man sagt jetzt soweit ist ein
integratoren der führt zusammen der welt
zusammenführen
der hat die menschen zu versöhnen ist
kann brücken bauen
auch aus seiner ganzen lebenserfahrung
heraus könnte man diese eigenschaften
auch der vize präsidentin zuordnen denn
die müsste sie ja eigentlich auch haben
wenn sie nach einem noch höheren amt
strebt für sie wird das jetzt ein echter
test denn dass ihr diesen ärger jetzt
hatte dass sie 20 16
bereits mit diesem ehrgeiz in den senat
einzog dass da noch mehr drin ist für
sie das ist erkennbar
aber man hat ja in den vorwahlen gesehen
dass das nicht so einfach liegt sie ist
nun vize präsidentenamt verwalten sie
angerufen hat sie ist sehr früh aus
ihren eigenen verein ausgeschieden noch
vor der ersten verein noch vor ist sehr
ausgeschrieben weil ist überhaupt nicht
lief die umfragewerte waren schlecht
sieht hat sie eine schlechte stimmung in
ihrem wahlkampfteam
es gab gerüchte dass die leute schlecht
behandelt und so als es ist keineswegs
so dass diese karriere
der ärgert dahinter aber dass das
vorgezeichnet ist dass sie auch
präsident ist die musste ich da erst
bewähren
ich wollte noch eine kleinigkeit anfügen
zu dem was vorher gesagt wurde
ich sehe das nicht ganz so negativ also
auch was den linken flügel der
demokraten anbelangt und drohende
spaltung
ich glaube wenn diese doppelte krise in
amerika pandemie und wirtschaftskrise
ein gutes hat wenn man das ohne zynisch
sein zu wollen zu sagen darf dann ist
doch dass beiden immer sagen kann 'die
bedeute jetzt lasst uns erst mal die
ganz wichtigen dinge lösen und wir
kümmern uns und vieles andere später
aber ihr werdet doch einsehen dass wenn
hier bin wir hier täglich 3000 menschen
verlieren
das ist gerade wichtigeres gibt und ich
glaube das wird in der ersten zeit bis
wir hoffentlich im sommer oder
frühherbst die amerikanische
gesellschaft durchgesetzt haben und
diese krise an dem ihn unter kontrolle
haben wird ihm bis dahin mit dem das
retten und dann muss er in der tat wenn
er das hinter sich hat zu sehen dass er
neben der wii
belebung der wirtschaft auch legislativ
was was vorlegen was sozusagen die
unterschiedlichen parteien beschädigt
natürlich spukt das heißt ja aber
eigentlich er muss jetzt erstmal mit
sehr pragmatischen dingen oder ist mit
sehr pragmatischen dingen konfrontiert
also diese aufbruchstimmung die es zum
beispiel bei obama
2009 gab die fehlt jetzt im land
möglicherweise aus nachvollziehbaren
gründen weil man eben ganz andere sorgen
hat
na ja also ich glaube ein aufbruch würde
schon davon ausgehen wenn man quasi die
arbeitslosigkeit im land wieder heil zum
höhepunkt der pandemie 22 millionen
amerikaner arbeitslos jeder zehnte
leidet an nahrungsmittelknappheit
das sind wirklich als die leute leiden
die opioid krise mit der wir uns zur
wahl 20/16 ganz intensiv befasst haben
ist natürlich nicht weniger wort
geworden in dieser zeit also das wären
schon deutliche erfolge wenn er da
schnell was leisten kann wenn geld in
die verschiedenen taschen fließt wenn er
gerade bestimmte wirtschaftsbereiche
retten kann die eben zum beispiel mit
der kurzzeit und den ganzen in diversen
programmen die die bundesregierung sich
ausgedacht hat gerettet werden oder
zumindest noch ins trockene gebracht
werden das gibt es in amerika natürlich
alles nicht wenn er da leisten kann
danach arbeiten kann dann ist das doch
ziemlich viel oder hat heute noch einmal
dazu aufgerufen die amerikaner mögen
können seien sie mögen optimistisch
seien sie mögen rastlos seien sie mögen
wieder die amerikanische energie frei
legen die doch teilen kursen der
amerikanischen genetik ist also ich sehe
das jetzt nicht so skeptisch da muss es
ist wie gesagt ist muss schnell gehen
und die leute müssen ist vor allen
dingen eben schnell spüren noch einen
kurzen putt zu den demokraten ein
taktischer fehler den joe biden gemacht
hat er hat sich bislang jedenfalls und
sein kabinett zwar ein sehr diverses und
der interessantes kabinett
zusammengestellt aber eben noch keine
rolle wirklich mit dem linken flügel
gesetzt und da haben wir eigentlich
drauf gewartet nachdem er diese
koalition geschmiedet hat als klar war
dass er der frankfurter war das eine
oder jedenfalls ein repräsentant das
würde ja auch noch mehr machen würde
das ist irgendwie klar werden würde ja
ja ich kann nicht nur mit euch als
linkem flügel sondern ihr gehört quasi
wirklich zur großen haben wir dazu ihr
kriegt hier sprach befugnisse und
entscheidungsgewalt und das ist eben
noch nicht passiert er hat die
zentristen die mit ihm damals auf den
vorfall bühnen stand die hat er gesetzt
also das ist meiner meinung nach ein
taktisches signalfehler gewesen also
völlig völlig einverstanden und das
einzige was man halt nur zur erklärung
noch vielleicht dazu liefern darf das
hänge auch davon ab dass bis zum
sechsten januar der senatsmehrheit nicht
klar war und möglicherweise der
pessimismus groß war dass die demokraten
nicht beide senatssitze im süden holen
und dann muss man eben wissen minister
kann man nur nennen also man kann sich
vorschlagen aber ernennen nur mit
zustimmung des senates und wenn der
senat republikanisch gewesen wäre dann
hätte hier konto sagen könne also wenn
neben mir einen nicht linken
arbeitsminister vorschlag tja wenn ihr
unbedingt bernie sanders nominieren
wollt dann nicht mit mir und vielleicht
hat sich also wenn man das jetzt noch
mal übersetzt beiden ist halt hat zu
früh zu viele posten besetzt und sich
nicht die möglichkeit offen gelassen
ebenso wie das gesagt wurde auf einen
senat sieg in beiden vor in den beiden
senatswahlen zu reagieren dass er eben
notfalls auch ohne die republikaner oder
gegen die republikaner sein
personaltableau mit eigenen stimmen
durchsetzen kann und so fahren ja das
ist glaubt dass das wird sich rächen
nicht denn irgendetwas muss er der
linken ist klar dafür hat er jetzt mein
bürgermeister als arbeitsminister und
ich habe eine neue bürgermeister war
vielleicht sollten wir in den letzten
minuten der sendung noch den blick nach
außen senden davon über r struck ich
hab's ja gesagt sie leiten ein
forschungsprojekt transatlantische
beziehungen europa gelüste die ja nach
einem us präsidenten der die alte
partnerschaft wiederbelebt oder
zumindestens europa nicht wie die
bucklige verwandtschaft behandelt würde
die man sich schämen muss wird denn der
alte kontinent diesem begehren erhöht
werden oh ja schauen sie sich bitte nur
dieses team
anthony blinken eigentlich nur
frankophile sondern eine französisch
sprechender außenminister der besser
französisch spricht als mancher franzose
der in frankreich aufgewachsen ist eine
seniorin führungskraft eben nationalen
sicherheitsrat wenders lot die eine
praxis beraterin ist eine nationale
sicherheitsberaterin für die
vize-präsidentin die botschafterin in
bulgarien war und die
europaangelegenheiten in state
department geleitet hat und die
diplomatische kaderschmiede geleitet hat
sechs fälle wenn der als wirklich
singuläres wir nie seiner generation in
der außenpolitische strategie gilt als
nationaler sicherheitsberater
ich muss ihnen sagen als
transatlantische politikerinnen und als
europapolitikerin geht mir das herz auf
wir haben in den letzten zwei jahren in
europa nämlich nach unserer schockstarre
sehr wohl nachgearbeitet ich habe jetzt
das gefühl dass die amerikanische
regierung dass gerade diese personalien
den europäern erstmal mit dem mut
begegnet werden denn sie wissen sehr
wohl dass die europäer jetzt
wasserträger waren um die multilaterale
architektur aufrechtzuerhalten die
funktionalität der nato aufrecht zu
erhalten das hat europa leisten können
das ist deutlich ausbaufähiger und die
europäer haben aber gezeigt dass sie
dazu bereit sind auch wenn wir natürlich
intern große debatten haben wir über
unsere eigene souveränität et cetera
aber man kann sich doch jetzt auf neue
art und weise auf augenhöhe begegnet die
herausforderungen sind groß
russland china digitales klimapolitik
und ich glaube da haben viele
denkfabriken und eben auch meine aber
auch in washington schon gute ideen auf
die straße gebracht also ich glaube das
wird jetzt doch sehr schnell hinunter
und transatlantik an kann das herz
aufgeht manager da es gibt ja wenig
sichtbare kontakt im moment auf
internationaler ebene zur administration
dass er etwas schwerfällig angelaufen
das hat ein paar tage gedauert bis das
wahlergebnis endgültig klar war aber es
gab dann mit verzögerung die höflichen
glückwünsche an den neuen amtsinhaber
band wird denn diese außenpolitische
apparat der beiden administration so
richtig anspringen und daneben auch
außenpolitische
aktivitäten sichtbar werden parallel zu
dem was eben in der innenpolitik jetzt
zu geschehen hat
also es gibt signale dass lincoln der
außenminister der kürzlich aus minister
am montag durch den senat beschädigt
wird und es gibt auch signale dass dann
sehr bald bündnispartner auf der anderen
seite des trans des des atlantiks sich
in bewegung setzen werden um erste
gespräche jetzt für das hat natürlich
dann wird glaube ich nicht mit großer
entourage heißen können wegen der
pandemie aber dass das wird glaube ich
nach der bestätigung des personals sehr
schnell erfolgen
ein grund warum das bisher nicht
stattgefunden hat übrigens mit fun zu
tun und mit der erfahrung
20 16 20 meter beginnen denn russland
affäre die demokraten oder die künftige
beiden administrationen hatte angst dass
kontakte vorzeitige kontaktaufnahme zu
bündnispartner sitzt dann verheizt
werden durch kampf nach dem motto sie an
der ist noch gar nicht sein wahlergebnis
ist gar nichts entschieden
zertifiziert er hat ja sowieso
wahlbetrug begangen und schon verkauft
verkaufte wieder amerikanische
interessen und lässt sich dort über den
tisch ziehen von chinesen genauso wie
von deutschland usw
das heißt man war sehr vorsichtig von
amerikanischer seite vorzeitig mit den
partnern in kontakt zu treten und wird
das jetzt glaube ich sehr schnell nach
worden der wird ja auch möglicherweise
wenn er bei einem deutschen thema
bleiben dem deutschen auch nicht immer
das liefern können was ich dir wünschen
stichwort nord stream 2 wird ja auch
beiden sagen wollen sie nicht es gibt ja
jetzt auch sanktionen gegen die
weißrussische verlegeschiff ist eine
kompromiss- möglichkeit zu sehen bei
diesen streitpunkten gerade mit
deutschland also ich glaube nicht ich
bin nicht so optimistisch dass europa
hier also wirklich das erste sein wird
sowieso dass das beiden sich damit
befindet ist egal ob blinken der safe
state ist oder nicht aber nein also ich
glaube die haben wie gesagt ja muss
präsident für alle amerikaner und alle
amerikaner sind nicht damit
einverstanden
also mit nord stream und sowas und auch
die situation mit russland das das ist
das wird sehr kritisch gesehen
also ich glaube nicht dass er also auch
stich strafzöllen und sowas sofort
zurück also zurückgezogen wird
er kann sich das nicht politisch leisten
und sie eine vorstellung reform habe von
marschall wie im moment der
gemütszustand von menschen wie sie den
chip in und von wladimir putin sind
jetzt in angesichts der tatsache dass
ein neuer präsident kommt der zumindest
in bezug auf vladimir putin
möglicherweise anders tickt als der
vorgänger wie sehen diese beiden anderen
supermächte diese politische umwälzungen
den usa wir sehen das ja nicht so
positiv also auch meinungsumfragen haben
ergeben russland ist das einzige land in
europa das eine negative einstellung zu
diesem regierungswechsel hat und für sie
da ist es eine offene frage weil es wird
für ein ungemütlicher wenn tatsächlich
amerika und europa egal zusammenarbeiten
und dass das notwendig ist und von
beiden seiten erst mal theoretisch
angestrebt wird dass man wieder eine
gemeinsame strategische politik macht
das der meinung bin ich auch aber ich
bin geprägt durch den übergang von bush
zu obama und damals war das problem dass
jeder dachte ja der wechsel muss von der
anderen seite kommt nicht er obama
dachte naja dass die europäer mit dem
bus nicht wollten ist ja klar aber mir
zuliebe werden die auch jetzt amerika
entgegenkommt europäer dachte nee nee
der obama wird sich bewegen und wir
müssen uns nicht verändern das ist
sozusagen die eigentliche psychologische
falle
beide seiten müssen bereit sein auf den
anderen zuzugehen und zugeständnisse zu
machen sonst wird das nichts wird denn
wird denn joe biden oder jetzt blinken
der außenminister das angebot von heiko
maas annehmen deutsche hilfe beim aufbau
der demokratie in form eines neuen
marshallplans das war genau diese
arroganz nicht also an müssten gehört
den amerikanern demokratie beibringen
nicht dass das ist der falsche ton
wir haben gemeinsame interessen und
müssen überlegen wie wir jeweils mal ein
paar zugeständnisse machen damit das
auch zu einer gemeinsamen aktion wird
vielleicht die richtige idee aber da hat
er leider nicht ins wahlprogramm der
demokraten geguckt werden dass es einen
kongress der demokratin geben sollte es
stand schon im sommer ein parteiprogramm
von joe biden
hat herr maas vielleicht nicht wirklich
die ausdrucksstarke also nicht möglich
gewesen das war ein bisschen schade aber
doch dass das da beide seiten jetzt
schneller zueinander finden könnte ich
könnte mich glaube das steht außer frage
und ich glaube wenn uns die letzten vier
jahre was oder was uns gelehrt haben
weil nämlich die tatsache dass wir
einander doch nicht so gut verstehen wie
wir das immer vielleicht dachten wir
haben vielleicht ähnliche oder die
gleichen werte wie würden sie mich auf
die gleiche art und weise priorisieren
und ich finde diese ganzen dinge gehören
offen auf den tisch gepackt aber wie
gesagt ich glaube wir europäer haben
nach gearbeitet in den letzten gerade
die letzten zwei jahren und ist es jetzt
ein verhältnis was doch eher auf
augenhöhe stattfindet wir haben alle
verstanden dass wir ja vielleicht nicht
mehr die leitmärkte sein können bzw dass
wir uns diesen status neu erarbeiten
müssen dass wir uns gegen autokratische
mächte wie russland und china nur dann
richtig und korrekt absetzen können und
den mehrwert der demokratie
unterstreichen können den wir jetzt
zusammen machen
also das sind interessen die man jetzt
deutlich formulieren kann da sind
europäer deutlich besser geworden in den
letzten zwei jahren 18 monaten
und deswegen bin ich bleibe ich bei
diesen fragen doch optimistisch wir
können ja gut anders miteinander reden
das ist auch ein guter ausblick für den
schluss der sendung ich bedanke mich bei
frau usa hat die nelson und bei
christoph von marschall hier bei kathrin
globisch druck und bei majid sattar
zugeschaltet aus den usa aus boston
vielen dank für das gespräch
die zuschauer morgen oder genauer gesagt
am donnerstag wir haben ja schon fast
donnerstag also um 22.15 dann lieder die
nächste phoenix runde mit dem titel cdu
unter neuer führung kann laschet die
partei einen bleiben sie bei phoenix
[Musik]